en la periferia de Nápoles se encuentra
un museo particular dedicado a uno de
los deportistas más conocidos del mundo
Diego Armando Maradona aquí máximo
viñati conserva preciosamente objetos
que pertenecieron al jugador Este es un
zapato especial Porque con este Diego
jugó el Mundial del 86 dos años después
de su muerte El Recuerdo del campeón
argentino sigue intacto para máximo y su
familia sus padres eran amigos
personales de Maradona
Miren esta foto fue el día del
cumpleaños de mi hermana aquí se ven
Diego mi papá y mi mamá hoy en día mi
mamá cuando lo ve en televisión llora
porque para ella fue como un hijo el
dolor todavía lo sentimos todos los
napolitanos pero para nosotros sigue
vivo porque Maradona es inmortal llamado
y calcio
una admiración que se siente por toda la
ciudad paseando por Nápoles no es
extraño toparse con gigantografías de
Maradona
en el ajetreado centro histórico esta
Plaza se ha convertido en el punto de
encuentro de los fanáticos del pibe de
oro en este segundo aniversario de su
desaparición el delantero argentino
sigue siendo venerado aquí para nosotros
los napolitanos el es casi una religión
entonces de vez en cuando tenemos que
venir aquí así como otros van a la
iglesia de rezar Nosotros venimos aquí a
rendirle homenaje
Todos aquí recuerdan la espectacular
carrera deportiva de Maradona con el
Napoli en donde jugó entre 1984 y 91
años Durante los cuales el equipo
conquistó los mayores triunfos de su
historia Dos copas de Italia y una copa
europea Maradona cuando Maradona llegó a
Nápoles transformó el grupo en un equipo
importantísimo combatimos a equipos que
en esa época eran inalcanzables para
nosotros y gracias a Maradona logramos
ganarles con Maradona
un legado que inspira hoy en día a toda
una nueva generación de futbolistas en
Nápoles que esperan seguir los pasos del
que muchos consideran el mejor jugador
de fútbol de todos los tiempos